la crise sanitaire et économique pèse
ratel sur nos feuilles d'impôts non
promet le ministre du budget gérald
darmanin pas tout de suite en tout cas
pourtant la dernière crise économique a
impacté l'impôt sur le revenu c'était en
voici comment les ménages ont été
touchés il n'y a plus d'argent dans les
caisses qui qui va payer
est-ce que ça va augmenter les impôts en
2008 c'est une évidence il faut agir sur
le plan budgétaire
toucher aux impôts non répond le premier
ministre françois fillon
pas de hausse d'impôt votre engagement
qu'une hausse d'impôts et d'ailleurs
dans le texte qui va être proposé au
parlement demain soir il n'y a aucune
augmentation de dépenses publiques en
2009 le président nicolas sarkozy
réaffirme qu'il n'y aura pas de hausse
des dizaines de milliards d'euros
provenant des finances publiques sont
injectés dans les banques et certains
contribuables craignent des
répercussions s'asseoir de ne pas chez
nous encore et toujours pas de hausse
d'impôt sur le revenu c'est même le
contraire
au début du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy le gouvernement avait amorcé une
baisse des impôts
il la poursuit en 2009 pour 5 millions
de foyers et pour trois autres millions
il est annulé
l'effort budgétaire est concentré sur la
réduction des dépenses de l'état
7 1 milliards d'euros que l'état aurait
perçu qu'il n'a pas perçu et qu'il a
sont restés aux français et qui sont
venus doper le pouvoir d'achat des
français en cette période
en cette période de crise toujours est
il que le chômage augmente que la
relance est encore loin que les voisins
grecs espagnols et portugais valeur
économique dégringoler la france en 2010
porte toujours ses efforts sur les
dépenses d'état passion les
contribuables le gouvernement refuse
d'employer le terme de rigueur la
rigueur c'est quand on réduit les
dépenses et qu'on augmente les impôts
changement de stratégie en novembre 2011
le gouvernement a annoncé un gel fiscale
notions techniques qui a une incidence
pour les contribuables une hausse de 2 %
de l'impôt sur le revenu ça fait un ver
de 7 milliards de plus dans les caisses
de l'état de toutes les mesures
annoncées hier
c'est une de celles qui rapportent le
plus 2012 les socialistes arrivent au
pouvoir et hérite du dossier de la dette
française cette fois un effort est
demandé aux entreprises comme aux
ménages 2012 et 2013 dont les années du
choc fiscal marqué par une hausse
d'impôts sur le revenu
13 milliards d'euros en deux ans cet
effort je veux qu'il soit juste parce
qu'il est nécessaire pour réduire les
déficits redresser le pays son économie
en 2014
le gouvernement estime qu'il doit en
finir avec ce qui est qualifié de
matraquage fiscal par l'opposition les
efforts sont des leurres porté sur une
politique de l'offre au clair un soutien
pour relancer l'activité des entreprises
et une baisse des impôts pour les
revenus les plus bas
[Musique]